.
Thank you.
opening the committee of conference on house bill 1130 and welcome to at least two people who have until this year not been on such before representative actin and representative king from a you got that yeah from the health and human services committee the best committee in the house as you know well i'm on the senate side i know you are you can um one uh i have side by sides here in case anybody hasn't gotten them yet i think uh denise does we'll just see if the nephew does okay oh my gosh i've heard that oh it was Denise does?
We'll just see if the nephew does.
Okay.
Oh, my gosh.
I heard that.
Oh.
It wasn't original.
We'll take him out to the woodshed.
Not the woodshed again.
All right.
There's really two parts to this.
The original bill, as you can see from the side-by-side, the agree it's the restroom act it's very special conditions and we put in some safety and all of that the second part that somehow got attached to this is marriage license and registration.
And sometimes...
somehow got attached to this is marriage license and registration and sometimes one special case is still a precious person and needs to be addressed but sometimes one special case doesn't always make the best law and so um we we do what we can and there were some questions about it and patricia lovejoy once of the house and now a senior deputy secretary of state raised some objections but senator avard now to the rescue would you like to present yes uh basically um i i did uh go to the the secretary of state um mr scanlan and i addressed the issues and he said well and then he he did some research for me as well and he said if you just add after a town clerk uh if unable or before town clerk if so on line 15 it says if either party is unable to appear in person the city clerk or town Thank you.
unable or before town clerk if so on line 15 it says if either party is unable to appear in person the city clerk or town clerk if unable shall accommodate and uh that that made all his worries go to flight so and i i spoke with him this morning about it could i ask please uhhuh.
So all I have is the side-by-side in front of you, so I don't have my name.
You're proposing if either party is unable to appear in person, the city or town clerk...
If unable.
Shall accommodate.
Well, the city or town clerk can't do anything if they're unable.
if they are not able to go in person.
Oh, they shall accommodate the parties and they're going to authorize the JG?
I'm sorry.
I really have difficulty with that.
I interrupted.
Sure.
And what I'll just let you know that what happened is that the Hollis, not Hollis, Hudson, after – well, let me just give you the story behind this.
was an individual two blocks away from town from from city hall a gentleman uh who didn't actually he couldn't speak English.
He had a difficult time speaking English.
He needed an interpreter.
He was in hospice two blocks away.
Before he died, he wanted to marry his partner.
And so he called up and he said senator would you mind going to the clerk's office and and through the interpreter and getting the information so i went to the clerk's office and i said uh you know i'm here on his behalf and would you or on their behalf and would you mind me you know doing this for them and they said what state state law and city ordinances say you can't do that.
And so I left, I made some phone calls, and we had some people that were going to donate so that they could go get an EMS to bring him there to the office so that he could fill out the paperwork.
I went back in and I said, is it okay if I get an ams to come in and help out in this situation and um they said yeah that's fine and by the way senator i i was incorrect it's just our office policy oh interesting so uh i left and then we did some more research and hudson was gracious enough to come and do it and accommodate across the river and come over and do it uh but apparently this happens uh very infrequently but they were able to do it and i thought you know this guy's just two blocks away there wasn't anybody in there there was nobody in there the parking lot was empty like honestly Honestly, so, um.
I just feel that, uh, that.
Your office policy is very cold.
And that generated this bill.
I appreciate the explanation and I'm very sympathetic to the plight of your constituent.
But as the chair has said, single bad experiences make for very bad law.
I have spoken to my town clerk who said, of course in a situation like that, we have a clerk, we have a deputy, one of us would go to the house of the person and accommodate them.
And that is what has happened in many cases and should happen in every case and actually did happen in your case.
You found another clerk who could go and do it.
From another town.
And that's, you can get married anywhere in the state with a marriage license from any town so the accommodation actually worked um i would be more comfortable with this if we make it clear that the city or town clerk has to do the accommodation rather than involving the justice of the peace that's that's the whole point well but you said that should they shall accommodate the parties by authorizing a new hampshire jp to act on behalf of the town clerk why don't we just compel the town clerk why don't we compel the town clerk to go and do it i'm with you 100 thank you um i you know you would say the town clerk shall accommodate it shall make yeah i i'm just thinking of how to how to say it the town clerk shall accommodate the parties by meeting with them where they are able by meeting with them at any spot in the town in which they are able to appear and that way they'd if if the person from walpole is in a nursing home in manchester the town clerk doesn't have to go there but their town clerk goes goes right so let me try writing this out sorry i guess we need to use the mic um i'm just wondering if the town clerks will be nervous because this could be abused because it said if either party is unable to appear in person but it doesn't give a why should we have due to medical reasons if you want to put that in there yeah for medical reasons such as hospice okay do you want to have a medical note or do you want to just say for medical reasons?
For medical reasons, yeah.
Okay.
And as we talk about it, I'm really getting back to the point of why do we need to put this in statute?
Because you have one bad apple.
I get it.
but it seems to me that the answer to that is better training and more firm training by the Secretary of State's office rather than putting into statute.
because I can also see, now that I'm going down the rabbit hole here, there may be places or situations into which a town clerk might not wish to insert themselves because they might not feel safe for whatever reason.
And I don't feel really comfortable compelling them into a situation in which they don't feel safe.
And again, I don't, it's, that is more somebody who's going to misuse the statute rather than otherwise.
But...
Mr.
Chair, can I respond to that?
I agree that's a rabbit hole.
There's nothing precluding them from taking the local law enforcement with them if they don't feel comfortable.
But I think all of these are very rare situations.
And what I think the underlying need is to make sure that this accommodation occurs in a reasonable situation like medically unable to attend or medically unable to get to the clerk's office.
If the clerk feels uncomfortable, there's nothing stopping them from taking an escort with them just my two cents i agree i have a quick quick question representative acton thank you um i'd have to concur with representative weber in in that i just wonder have have we made the point already to the clerks that they need to clean this up?
A lot of times just introducing the law and taking it this far gets the message across to them that they need to change this behavior.
I did consider that, but I also consider the fact that if we don't go forward, that we also send a message.
As the designated grumpy one today, if they don't do it, we'll shame the hell out of them in the press.
I just assume not have to do that.
Well, I mean, I don't like to do that now.
I don't like to use a big stick either, but I have one.
I could do that now.
And I chose rather to than to do that and to shame anybody because uh you know in addition you know i looked at the the clerk and i just said i'm not mad at you i'm not angry with you this is office policy uh i i don't that that just that's a spiral that i don't want to go down there's enough bad stuff out there already i just assume look, you're going to do it.
So even if we're not shaming the clerk, who's only acting under orders, we could have some publicity about how the policy in this community needs to change.
We could, or we could just make the change.
Okay.
And I think Representative Weber's cooking up an amendment here of some sort.
I like your idea of the clerk having to do it and that they could, you know, if you...
Well, I think it has...
My bottom line is it has to be the clerk because it has to be somebody who knows the right kinds of documents and the right kinds of things to look for.
And it is their responsibility.
They shouldn't have to be taking that responsibility just on a photograph of documents.
But I'm, I'm diddling with language here.
And I'm I'll propose the language.
I may, I may not be able to agree to it at the end, but I'll propose the language because I like words.
If either party is unable to appear, and we're not sure about whether we're putting medical reasons in there or not, the city or town clerk shall accommodate the parties by meeting in person with the parties at such other location within the city or town as may be convenient?
Well, if somebody's in hospice and they can't be moved.
That's another location in the city or town as may be convenient.
Okay, that's okay.
I mean, for that person, there's only one place that's convenient, but I need it to be in the city or town.
That means they're not forced to do a house call if there's another spot that they can do.
Right.
I don't know why they wouldn't want to do a house call or why you wouldn't just, you know, take an extra person along if you were on.
And, you know, if it's a hospice patient, it's a hospice.
You're just going to hospice.
I don't understand why somebody wouldn't just go to hospice.
And I'm, I mean, I really do think that sparing the feelings of the clerk in question here is a little much, because I certainly know of all kinds of accommodations that my clerk made.
For example, when my husband was ill and unable to get from the car into the town clerk's office, the town clerk came out.
And had he, I mean, there were offers to bring him ballots, for example, and other things at the house, should he need it.
I have actually lived this situation.
And I really think that the issue here is not the law.
The issue is the person and the policy, which just seemed to me to be staggeringly out of touch.
I would agree it's staggeringly out of touch.
I also think that if not forced, if somebody just has either an ego problem or just having a bad day somebody is being disenfranchised from the services which should be provided whether through sickness or whatever and i just feel that um i don't think this is this is earth shaking i don't think this is going to to all of a sudden make the whole state tremble because the clerks have to at least come up with some kind of a plan.
But human nature being as it is, if somebody's having a bad day, somebody can be disenfranchised.
And I just – I have issues with that, and I just witnessed it.
It took a senator to go on behalf of one individual and get turned down.
It took a senator because other people were attempting apparently prior to me so i'll call my senator and we still got shot down so if a senator can't do it if a state representative or or people that are in the community can't do it there's an issue shaming Shaming, I don't think, we can shame all day long, but if there's an arrogance or a situation where there's intransigence, it doesn't fix the problem, people get left behind.
So I just, I'm pretty, you know, I was really offended by this.
I was heartbroken.
I literally, I got all choked up.
I'm leaving the place.
I'm thinking, are you kidding me?
This is just office policy.
I'm still getting choked up.
And, you know, if a senator can't get it done because somebody's in training.
But you did, and it was done.
I would add, if I might, Mr.
Chair, that even if it's not office policy, currently a clerk could refuse to do this.
So we don't know how big a problem it is, but we know it's a problem that either whether it's policy or not a clerk right now can refuse to do to accommodate somebody who can't come into the office i have worked with many of the clerks across the state when i was on the select committee and i'm i'm appalled number one that it's policy and i would be appalled if a clerk didn't do it but they can and i think this closes that loophole without being onerous in addition i i just want to reiterate that this individual he only spoke spanish and uh he didn't know where else to cry out to so there there's a voice there that okay you get shot down um it's who's going to know?
Right?
You're not part of the commonwealth, if you will, or the general public where your complaint's going to be noted.
Would Representative Weber read the draft as we have it so far, please.
Okay.
If either party is unable to appear in person, and the question is whether you put in or leave out for medical reasons, but I've got it there sort of hanging, the city or town clerk shall accommodate the parties by meeting with the parties, by meeting in person with the parties sorry at such other location within the town or city city or town as may be convenient I like it so do we put in for medical reasons or not I would because I don't want it to be a free-for-all, you know?
Right, right, yeah.
I ran out of gas.
No, sorry.
I didn't want to come into town next Tuesday.
You drive out to the farthest reach.
Right, so for medical reasons.
Now, the way I've been running committees of conference so far and have not been yelled at for doing it is that we don't have to run down to OLS, get the amendment, bring it back, vote on it.
This is the amendment.
Once it is written on a fresh piece of paper, I'll march it down and if we all agree.
Sam Hill.
Nice bipartisan bill and I think it just helps those that might be I'll see it down, and if we all agree, submit.
Nice bipartisan bill, and I think it just helps those that might be isolated, and I think it's another way of us working together and sending a message that we do care about the individuals that maybe it is one.
We've heard that phrase before.
One left behind is too many.
Thank you.
You're writing my blurb, you know, right now.
Yeah.
I appreciate that, Mr.
Chair.
I just...
It says this...
I think, if anything, it sends a signal that we can work together for those that don't have a voice.
I don't know.
And we're working together on it.
And Representative Weber wrote the language.
As a gastroenterologist, the underlying bill is two thumbs up.
Yeah, no doubt.
I have many patients who will be thrilled.
President J.C.
Penney is not.
No.
So we're gonna have one more read of the amendment written on a clean crisp piece of paper and then we're going to vote on it and then we're going to sing one verse only of kumbaya and then we'll go our ways and so far my morning today is starting off the way my morning did yesterday.
And I'm hoping it won't turn out the way yesterday afternoon did, but I got another shot at it.
Yes, you do.
We had a good day yesterday.
You had a what?
Yeah, of course we did that.
We work like a event.
We like pilots.
Senator Guida.
What about Senator Guida?
We were talking totally unrelated to another bill in energy, and he put in the phrase forever source.
What do you think about it when she's making a pilot program and of course he's a pilot uh-huh no i thought you were talking about a pilot light with a gas no no and so we all have to talk it would be fly by night that's my comeback oh it's getting a little thick here I've finished writing maybe I would be a good time for me to reread this one more time.
Would the honorable gentle lady from Cheshire County please read?
What I've got here is 5A.
If either party is unable to appear in person for medical reasons, the city or town clerk shall accommodate the parties by meeting in person with the parties.
So it's both parties.
It's got to be both parties at such other location within the city or town as may be convenient.
All in favor of that for the second half of the bill.
Yes?
Aye.
We did for medical reasons.
Do you want to read it again, Mr.
Chairman?
If either party is unable to appear in person for medical reasons, comma, because it should be, the city or town clerk shall accommodate the parties by meeting in person with the parties at such other location.
You have it singular?
One location because both parties are together.
Got it.
Within the city or town as may be convenient.
Senator Sherman had your hand.
Oh.
I'm voting, yes.
Okay.
And the first, all right, now let's just take a look at the first part of this.
This is.
There were no changes, as far as I know.
We all agree then.
Yes.
Because we already did.
Okay, so I like the Senate version, and you like the House version.
Yes.
And we agree.
All right, we're done.
Thank you all.
Thank you.
Thank you very much and I'll mark will you be my neighbor oh let's take the trolley to wherever it goes.
All right, good.
Thank you.
Okay, so that's...
So that means we should use our microphones, and there's our last member.
John Janadian, do you know, I don't know if you know, Don, Stasandro, Daniel, John, you should probably come over here.
Thank you.
You know, I don't know.
Yeah, you're trying to come over here.
All right.
Okay, yeah, it's 11 o'clock so I'm sharing this.
So I will call the this committee of conference on house bill 355 to order and uh we did the introductions uh i i just let me start by let me just set this up we got we got house bill 355 last winter it's a three digit number was one that we had retained in the house the initial reaction was we weren't that interested in doing this at all but we did hear testimony from the grocers and the convenience store guys uh and we kind of slept on that over the summer and we we reconvened so what the bill calls for originally was for, back up.
Right now, Keno is just offered in establishments that pour liquor.
We all know that.
Okay.
So, so that, and I was on the original subcommittee looking at Keno years ago that came up with this restriction.
We didn't feel like having any convenience stores or the look wasn't that good.
You know, to have screens everywhere, gathering groups of people in a convenience store or a grocery store.
so when we heard testimony from the grocers and the convenience store people, they were saying, you know, sometimes people in a restaurant will leave before the number comes up, and they're going to have to cash.
They go to, you can cash your ticket out anywhere, anywhere that has a lottery machine.
So they were complaining that, wow, you know, we're doing all the work.
We're cashing these keynote tickets out, but we're not getting any remuneration for it.
So, okay, we kind of listened to them and we heard them.
So in the last fall in our meeting, it was, again, a retained bill, we came up with a compromise and we said, okay, you can sell keynote tickets, but no screens.
We don't want screens displaying the numbers where people would gather waiting there for the numbers.
And so that's the compromise that we had come up with.
And the voter out of our committee was 19 to 5.
We had 24 members then.
Then, and the prime sponsor of the bill was on Ways and Means then, and he actually made the motion.
Just tell you how he made the motion on the amended bill so when it went over to the senate committee and i i was there that day i wasn't going to testify and i was going to testify in the next bill um and i i did express a lot of this to the committee that um we really weren't in expanding keynote in this way in which there's the screens and this is not uncommon Charlie McIntyre is here he said you know there are places that would call I think there's some that call it keynote to go and that's basically basically what this is kino to go without the screens so that's and we we would like to uh our position is that we would we would like uh our our position to be considered the senate did consider the position and i think we fall on the side of if a community wants to authorize kendo to be played there and store owners want to have a screen i would question why no screen if the people that are the responsible parties both the community and also the store owner um says it's okay i'm sure if there's crowds in the store there are Thank you.
people that are the responsible parties both the community and also the store owner um says it's okay you know i'm sure if there's crowds in the store there are fire restrictions on the numbers of people and a store owner is not going to let a crowd develop so you know again i to me it seems like a specious interference in the conduct of business we note that as of today our revenues from lottery are down the price of gas is going up and so an additional revenue stream won't hurt us so that mean my concerns would be why are we bothering to interfere with the conduct of business if it's not in any way directly harming the state yeah yes you can respond that um yes you're correct one thing about keno it's it's an opt-in to the state.
Yes, you're correct.
One thing about Keno, it's an opt-in to the community.
But you know in those votes how many people really vote.
So let's say there's one grocery store in town or one convenience store in town.
And I go in and all I see is gambling going on in front of me.
I don't really like it.
I mean, I think our position is representing what I think most people would consider reasonable.
I would offer that.
I don't know a grocery.
I'm just going to put an array of screens up.
I might be willing to consider one screen limiting the number of screens but to say no screens to me seems counterproductive I'm wondering if that might be a position that the house might be what to consider no no we're not we're not willing to consider Mr.
Chairman I guess i guess i would question if a if a business if if a grocery store felt that a gathering of people waiting for numbers was interfering with the business.
And I might argue that one of the possibilities might be that as they're waiting for numbers, that they're actually buying more things.
there but why why would we not leave it to the business to decide whether it's detrimental to that numbers that they're actually buying more things there.
But why would we not leave it to the business to decide whether it's detrimental to that business or not?
I don't have any vested interest in that business, and I'm going to trust that probably none of us here have part ownership in a grocery store.
Or if we did, then we could go in and we could voice our opinion.
But if it got too burdensome for businesses, then they have the option of taking the screen out.
So we all remember when we didn't have Kino.
And Massachusetts was, you know, there were a lot of stores along the border at Keno, including Ted's Mobile.
Ted's Mobile stripped, other than selling gas, they stripped out everything that they sold and they said Keno in there.
They created Keno parlors.
So, I mean, there's no restriction here to prevent that from happening in all these other locations that we're talking about.
And we're not just talking about grocery stores.
We're talking about pharmacies as well, because any place that has a keynote machine and not a keynote machine, a lottery machine.
So I would again offer the possibility that maybe we limit to present keynote parlors to prevent prevent keynote parlors, we limit the number of screens to what would be an appropriate number, one, two, maybe base it on square footage.
But again, I think there's a way to satisfy your concerns, which we would like to do, as well as to allow the grocers, the convenience stores and everybody else to maintain the option of how they want to run their business i think that's that's probably a good position yes uh dick as uh representative brahmi noted uh kino is an opt-in uh there had to be an affirmative municipal vote to have it in the first place.
And as we considered this further expansion of Kino into convenience stores and grocery stores, there was discussion about whether this expansion was consistent with.
Or inconsistent with the proposal that municipalities that had opted in.
Acted on, in other words, they understood Keno in a certain way and was this inconsistent and we I think my recollection is that was this was discussed and our conclusion was it's okay if it's passive it's just buying selling tickets but it is an active screen is playing keynote and there's a substantial question of whether that would have made a difference in terms of the opt-in decision by the municipality in the first place because this is if you take the scenario suggested by representative Bromini is a substantial change for a small town that has one convenience store, for example, or one grocery store, and maybe another restaurant or two where they allow for Kino, but without the idea of it expanding into the other places.
So I just offer that as an additional consideration that I think steered our vote to some extent.
Yes, representing the senator.
I'm going to go back and say, why are we as legislators trying to tell a business how to run the business?
You know what?
If I hit a convenience store and I set up Kino and I noticed that there's a drop in my clients coming in, then, you know, I have the option of getting out of the business or getting rid of a screen or whatever it does to make that business successful.
But when you've got something permissive that the community has accepted, the business has opted in, and now the legislature is saying, well, okay, but everything else is fine, but no, you can only do this.
That does not make sense to me.
And, you know, it really just is a detriment to our economy if we're going to start thinking that we can run every business out there.
Well, first off, Representative Ames brought up a good point about the the if we're going to start thinking that we can run every business out there.
First off, Representative Ames brought up a good point about the towns that have opted in, opted in for establishments that pour liquor.
That's what their understanding was.
So there's no provision in here to go back and revote whether we want this in grocery stores grocery stores and in in convenience stores in our pharmacies or wherever uh that you know and uh i i i just think i mean as legislators i we we restrict certain things and in this case i just think it's a bad look and i'm i'm i'm gonna vote my conscience on that.
It's a bad look.
And I'm going to vote my conscience on that.
It's a bad look, I think, to have all of these.
I mean, lottery, yes.
Lottery's been around.
We're one of the oldest lotteries in the country, right?
But it's kind of there, but it's not in your face.
Putting screens up, it becomes in your face as a potential customer who may not like it.
And I'm going to defend them.
In which case, the customer can find another store or another restaurant.
In which case, the customer's feelings can be made evident to the owner of the store, who can then change his or her policy.
We allow store owners to require injecting a serum as a condition of employment.
We don't touch that.
We're not going to interfere with businesses.
And yet here we are in something as basically, in my opinion, unnecessary and interfering in the conduct of business by businesses that have themselves expressed the desire for this.
They accept your edict as chair of Ways and Means because they have no option.
I would submit that every business in the state wants to have that option, and I think we do them a disservice.
Let them be the determinants.
They're the ones that run the business.
The community knows that laws change.
We promise to pay retirement benefits.
And that changed.
So laws change all the time.
Again, I think this is something that can be accomplished with people who are willing to compromise in this committee of conference to accomplish something that's reasonable and reasoned.
We can limit the number.
We can limit the size.
Let the businesses choose whether or not they have them.
And house wage means already compromised.
This bill wouldn't have passed if we didn't do our compromise to say you can sell the tickets but no screen.
It wouldn't have passed.
And that's why we retained it.
It wasn't going to pass right away, and we retained it.
So we already compromised on the house side.
And, look, I'm always pro-businessiness as anybody.
So please, I don't want to appear like I'm restricting business.
This is small.
This is not huge.
And yes, it's a real attraction because we were very generous, very generous in the Kino establishments that use 8%.
They get 8%, if you recall.
That's really established.
I can understand why the grocers and the others.
But they're going to get 8% by selling tickets behind the window without a screen.
It may not, maybe, it isn't like we said no, no.
We said we just don't have the screen.
So I know I'm not going to budge.
Take a recess.
Thank you.
so take a research yes yeah Thank you.
thank you mr chairman the the senate would like to request a recess and reconvene tomorrow i don't know times that we'll let the staff work that out.
You and I on 2...
I got 7 tomorrow, but I'm willing to reconvene.
I know.
I'm on with you at 10 and at 11.
Yeah.
Sure.
All right.
Thursday's the possibilities if we get it in the morning, because I think we have until 3 o'clock Thursday to sign off.
Right.
Didn't have any of the people to come in.
So do you have a time in mind?
I don't have a time but i'd have to let my my schedule and my handler if you will take a look at that and he will get out to you post haste right let me take a look here yeah there's one at ten and we have one at 11.
i will tell you that the the one at 11 you'll like a little better but so how about if we could do one at 11 30.
so wednesday i've got we got pre-fiscal i got one at nine i got one at 9 30.
got one at 10.
i'm under one with you at 10.
right and then i have one at 11.
so maybe 10 30.
does 10 30 tomorrow work for anyone do you think that bill that would be shorter that one would be then i got i'm free until the afternoon i want to do it around at 1221.
1221 might go a little longer.
Why don't we want to try noon or one?
Let's get it done.
All right.
So noon.
Okay.
I guess I got to go schedule that.
I'll take that schedule Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'll open the Committee of Conference on HB 1431.
And a lot of new information has been brought forward about this bill, particularly the information from the domestic violence advocates and from the Attorney General in concern that this could open us up to lawsuits.
And also from, I had an email from the director of New Hampshire School Administrators Association also not to mention a lot of other emails but so I have some really deep concerns about this I do not want to see us putting kids it's such a fine line to remain parental rights and the child's rights and i just want to make sure that we're not setting kids up to self-harm to feel they have no one to talk to because while yes there are a lot of great parents out there, unfortunately, there are also some not-so-great parents out there.
And those are the kids that I feel are most vulnerable that I am deeply concerned about.
So Senator Gannon, sorry.
I was up in Conway speaking with a couple of principals yesterday doing some work up there, and we brought up this topic.
And one of the principals did bring up that he said, you know, they're mandated reporters if it was a counselor, the teacher, the principal, whoever the student talked to.
And if they thought there was a danger, if they knew the parent to be a violent person if they knew the person they could report that to DCYF so there is a safeguard already in place that if they knew a parent was predisposed to be a danger in any way otherwise I think you're doing a disservice if you didn't tell me or someone else as a parent that my child was we'll just probably I think you're heading towards LGBTQ plus issues.
If you're dealing with that and then you didn't tell me, wouldn't you be opening us the state up to liability because I wouldn't then know that my child potentially has an issue.
I don't get them help because you've left me in the dark.
If you keep if you don't inform the parents.
So I don't have a problem with, let's say, a counselor facilitating a conversation if the child says they feel okay with it.
But I'm concerned that a child will not even go and talk to a counselor now knowing that this is law.
And that's what really concerns me.
I don't want to keep parents in the dark.
You know, I think a lot of issues have been brought up over the past two years.
But this comes down to children's safety for themselves, not just from their parents, but from themselves.
If they feel they don't have anyone to talk to at that school, what are they going to do if they don't feel like they can talk to someone at home?
So that's where I'm really concerned.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
And just, you know, staying on this issue that has been raised by, and I agree with you, Representative Rice, that some of these issues have come to us a little bit later.
And, you know, we didn't necessarily hear all these issues in the Senate and I think vice versa in the House.
And I think it probably is the case that as the bill progressed, people took a closer look at it as they saw how the various bodies had amended it and were able to, you know, do a deeper dive into the implications.
So I think i think you know i think we're in a space now where a lot of those implications are fleshed out and the unintended consequences are fleshed out but specifically on the lgbtq issue um i think we have to look at that issue also in the context of children's mental health because we know you, you know, setting aside the LGBT community, we know that there's been an increase in the need for children's mental health services and that we have seen more children at our emergency room.
So this is a really critical time to make sure that we're getting kids into services that they need.
And of course, children are in school for the majority of their days, right?
And so school does need to be that place where if a child seeks counseling for whatever reason, that that is a safe place.
And, you know, we got some information from the Trevor Project, which is the world's, as they describe, the world's largest suicide prevention and mental health organization for LGBTQ youth.
They said that last year they had they served over 660 contacts from New Hampshire and they fear that passage of this bill would only increase the need for their services which is you know we just don't want to be in a place where we're you know um children are scared to seek services and that they get to a point where they are you know at an elevated um you know elevated so much that they are considering suicide they also gave some really startling statistics about how um when children non-binary youth were asked about this bill and other bills like this they said that they were scared that bills like this make them scared and they and and for good And I think you know so many you know I know everyone on this committee are excellent parents and I and I um I know that I would want to know if my child was struggling but the reality is is that we don't know what's happening in everyone's home and yes children are uh teachers are mandatory reporters but they don't know what's going on at home.
Absolutely.
It could be very likely that a school would have no idea whether a home would be a gender affirming space or a safe space for someone to explore their gender identity.
So we don't, the school district may not know if that's a dangerous place.
And this this trevor project provided some data that only one and three transgender and non-binary youth report that their home is gender non-conforming furthermore 29 of lgbtq youth have experienced homelessness been kicked out or run away um and it goes on And so I just feel like it's just such a dangerous time to be messing with this balance.
And, you know, I think because we've gotten all this information about children's mental health issues, LGBTQ issues, domestic violence issues, we received some information about how this could potentially be really dangerous for survivors and children of survivors.
So I think we I think we could all agree today that parental rights are important and fundamental and parents are, you know, the foundation of a child's life.
But we this bill really upsets the balance.
Thank you.
Senator Carson, thank you.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Um, I'm, you know, we had our public hearing.
Um, we didn't hear, we didn't hear anybody complain about LBGTQ folks, domestic violence.
So now at this point, I find it really offensive that we've been bombarded with bulk emails about how we're going to destroy these kids.
This is not the way to have a conversation.
And I really am very, very concerned at the tactics of outside groups and what they're doing.
We are here because we are concerned about our children.
And the fact that parental rights have been eroded over time.
So it gets to the point where a parent is excluded.
And, you know, I want to know, when did teachers become mental health counselors?
When did that happen?
Do they get a special designation with their license when they go to school?
They don't have the background to deal with that.
We hire teachers to teach.
We hire administrators to administrate our school system.
Do they have the background in order to do this, to handle this issue?
Or should we now require it as part of their licensing that they now have to take classes and be licensed mental health counselors?
Is that what we need to do?
I disagree with the fact that kids are in school the majority of the day.
They're in school maybe five or six hours a day.
The of the time they're with at they're at home or they're with their families including weekends so they're not with the school 24 hours a day and to think that a school is going to treat a child for some sort of mental issue that the child would be having how does that happen because you can't take your child to an emergency room and get them treated without parents a parent's permission but yet a school can counsel a child without the parent's permission how does that work How does that work and this is the problem here is that too much too much it's too much parents have the right to know what's going on with their children do we need to put some safeguards in place yes I would agree but no teacher should be counseling a student referring them for mental health services what how does that work telling them well you're exploring your gender well you know maybe you should go see this person or go go over here or go do this without the parents knowing.
How does that happen?
But it happens in school, but it's okay because the child is supposed to be safe.
It's a safe environment.
We've had, I don't know how many times we have had hearings where people have said to us, a child's brain doesn't develop until the age of 25.
Okay.
But yet you are going to trust a 10-year-old, a 12-year-old, a 15-year-old to start making decisions like this on their own?
With support from a teacher who, by the way, has no relation to that child other than the fact that they are a teacher.
Are you now going to say, okay, you're going to be responsible for what happens?
Do teachers want to assume that responsibility?
Do districts want to now assume that responsibility?
Is that what we want to have happen?
a lot of things i'm sorry i i don't mean to attack you and i hope you don't think i'm attacking you but this is an extremely complicated issue this is not an easy thing to to think about but i also think we need to think about the role of schools in in state of New Hampshire.
Do we want them to assume this responsibility?
If we do, we better put some safeguards in there for the parents, for the kids, and for the schools.
Because right now there are none.
What safeguards are in place?
So if a teacher counsels a student on their gender dysphoria and the parents find out can they sue the school can they individually sue that teacher for interfering in the parent child relationship do schools want to accept that liability i can't answer that question but at some point we are going to have to tackle with that issue.
Thank you.
Representative DeSimone.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
In some respects I absolutely agree with senator.
But I'm also thinking about when 100 years ago I was in school, we had guidance counselors.
They still have guidance counselors.
And those counselors were to guide us, hopefully in the right direction, when we had an issue, be it academic or social.
Teachers are expected to teach and guide a child through their academics and their behavior.
And when the teachers see that a child's behavior is conducive of issues at home they are mandated reporters and shall report When most parents who are good parents get this information.
Then the school and the parents get to treat that child so they become happy, well-adjusted members of society.
But then you have the child who comes to a guidance counselor, a teacher, a secretary in the office, and says, I don't know what I'm going to do with my life.
I have nobody to turn to.
I cannot tell my parents I'm afraid to go to my parents.
I don't have any family members that I can go to.
I don't have any family members that I can go to to tell them that I have a transgender question or that I'm gay or I'm lesbian.
I cannot tell them I don't know how they're going to react, please help me.
Is it the school's story to tell?
Is it the guidance counselor's story to tell?
Or is it the guidance counselor's responsibility to guide the child until the child feels safe do we want to put kids in a position where they now no longer have that guidance counselor to go to because they know the guidance council is going to tell the parents then what happens then the suicide rate goes up.
So just so we're aware, I also received an email.
I reached out to the Attorney General's office to have them look over this.
And they said that someone was going to be here, and I don't know if they are.
Yes, you are?
Yes, he's here.
I'd like to have you, if you don't mind, come and and give us some because everyone didn't receive the email so just so that everyone's clear on what we did thank you and your attorney lock yes there we go yes i'm attorney lock i'm assistant attorney Sean Locke with the Department of Justice.
I direct the Civil Rights Unit there, a role I've held for about three years now, and before that I was a prosecutor in the Criminal Justice Bureau.
I was asked to kind of provide some input on behalf of the department, and it's important to note the department doesn't take a position on the overarching legislation, but looked at this to see if there are potential conflicts with the state's anti-discrimination laws or potential federal law and so with respect to the state's anti-discrimination laws in 2019 the state adopted a provision that prohibited discrimination in public education it provides that no person shall be excluded from participation in denied the benefits of or be subjected to discrimination in public schools because of their among other things sex gender identity and sexual orientation and our one of the concerns we saw here was that certain portions of the current version of the bill specifically require school staff to promptly notify a student's parents about the student's gender expression or identity should the school or school employee initiate investigator find the need for any action by school authorities related to the student policies governing gender identity expression or identity and so it could be construed to require for lack of a better word school staff to out students against the students wishes where you have that student who expresses a fear that their parents find out or their or their guardians find out because they don't know whether and it may just be they don't know how their parents are going to react their parents may be very supportive but that's not necessarily the thought process of a 14 year old or a 12 year old they may be afraid of that reaction they may not be ready to express that to their parents and they're looking for some support and guidance in answering that particular question but this if the student were to approach a staff person about this or seek the protection of the district or the school's transgender kind of anti-discrimination policy, their parents would have to be told at that point.
And so the concern here in the conflict or the potential conflict we see with the anti-discrimination law arises because the language specifically targets students based upon their gender identity or expression on their students which may deny those students the benefits of those particular policies designed to protect them it also there are other sections that dealt with student extracurricular activities so if a student were to go to a meeting of I apologize I don't know if they're still called this but when I was in high school they're called gay straight alliances um to go to a meeting of that where they might seek kind of support from their peers or friends that that may have to be reported to their parents and again lead to them being kind of outed to their parents um and even in with respect to federal law federal courts have recognized that laws that target or classify individuals based on their sexual orientation or being trends transgender constitute as sex-based classifications and if and when um the legislation requires schools to inform parents that the student is seeking the protections afforded to them by the school's policies protecting transgender students it's only going to impact transgender students it's not going to impact non-transgender students it's also kind of important to note in this particular area with respect to the potential liability the u.s department of justice has been made sent a we'll call a dear colleague expressing its It's intent to pursue litigation on behalf of LGBTQ minors and youth, directed more specifically, probably more specifically, other laws like those in Alabama and policies other states have adopted with respect to care for transgender youth, but they are looking very closely at issues that might exclude or prevent trans lgbtq youth from being fully protected by the law we also just noted some concerns around privacy here and there's case law where in circumstances where essentially public officials and most in one context it was a police department threatened to out a student or out a teenager the teenager later later committed suicide and the municipality was liable for that person's death and ended up settling.
It's a concern here where again, what a student may do in the face of that fear of being outed could expose the schools to liability.
And that's kind of a summary here of the email i sent i'm happy to provide that to the rest of the committee as well and take questions thank you senator carson thank you madam chair um i also i read your your email and i'd like to point out that and you talked about a young man um who was in the process of being arrested and they threatened to out him to his grandfather.
This person was 18 years old and legally an adult.
So I think that there's we need to realize that there is a difference here.
Someone who's 18, they're legally adult.
They're they're responsible for themselves.
They can do whatever they want to do.
But we're talking specifically about people that are younger than the ages.
I would like to add some clarification.
You had talked about clubs and parents being informed.
This wasn't just specifically dealing with one type of club.
This was affecting all students.
So you're not looking at one particular group of students that are going to be treated differently than every other student, any other student in a school.
All students are going to be treated the same.
all parents are going to be notified of the clubs that their children belong to so can you can you clarify that for me because to me that sounds like you're misrepresenting what we had uh in the bill so i think the concern there arises that specifically lgbtq identified students might not feel safe or able to avail themselves of those programs or particular clubs without exposing themselves to the risk of being essentially outed to their families.
And so in that way, those particular students may be being denied the benefits of being able to participate in those groups that may not be, that may be available to those who do not identify as LGBTQ.
That's where the concern arises.
And the same thing you know and but at the same time the primary concern is that there are specific provisions in the senate version of the bill that do specifically identify gender identity and expression as a basis to have to make reports to parents and so that you know that specifically identifies that particular group of students as opposed to any other group.
May I follow up with another question?
Thank you.
One of the questions that I had concerned school personnel offering counseling.
People that do not have mental health backgrounds, they have a degree in education, they're not licensed as counselors, except perhaps a guidance counselor.
And I'm really not sure whether or not they have any kind of license to be a school guidance counselor and what kind of educational background they have.
because much like representative de simone when i went to school our guidance counselors were there to just give us counseling on our plans moving forward from high school, whether it's going on to college, going on to work.
They did not get involved in personal issues with students.
That obviously has changed, and I do think it's going to be worthwhile for the legislature to look into the qualifications of both teachers and guidance counselors and school administrators if they are going to assume this role.
because you want to make sure that if a child is going to be receiving mental health counseling, you want to make sure that they're getting counseling from someone who has the appropriate educational background, not someone who's just going to, okay, yes, I understand.
Someone who's really going to try to help the student get through this process because obviously you're not going to inform the parents.
So the parents are not going to get the opportunity to try to help their own child through this process.
But I want to know what law enables a minor to invoke protections of the government and to do so with the assistance of the government keeping parents from finding out.
So there is necessary.
So, you know, if there were a situation where a parent were to come to the school and explicitly ask, has my child sought, you know, gender affirming kind of care or something like that from the school, I don't know that there is a law that would say the school can't answer that question or would be, you know, prohibited or would have a basis to refuse to answer that question.
The issue is more, I think, my understanding having kind of talked to kind of both LGBTQ advocates and school advocates is the idea behind some of the policies in place is to kind of support the students as they prepare to come out to their parents and not kind of have the kind of this traumatic forcible outing process, but to have the student come out on their own terms when they're able to do so and feel like they are in a safe kind of mental place to be able to do that um so so I guess to answer your question directly no there isn't necessarily a law I think that I can think of that would say a school has you know absolutely cannot and that's the balancing here and I think in the section you referenced about the individual who committed suicide part of what that case is there for is that this case has been used by advocacy groups to sue school districts dealing with minors in these circumstances and that has been those have resulted in settlements against those districts but there is kind of an unsettled area of law about the privacy kind of balancing the privacy of a minor versus the interests the parents.
And it's not to say that there isn't an interest that the parents have in knowing this information.
For example, if the student was engaging in dangerous behavior, there wasn't any way to explain that without essentially outing the student, there may be an obligation to do so.
But there's a difference, I think, in terms of a student just going to a gay-straight alliance and then having their parents told, and a student who might be kind of engaging in, you know, far more dangerous behavior that the school becomes aware of or that happens at the school.
And then this has to be kind of as part of the context of why this information came to light.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
um do you know if the schools if schools if they engage in this kind of counseling with students are they required to keep records as part of the students um i guess packet of information i don't know off the top of my head that piece of information um certainly you know there may be a risk to schools if you had completely unlicensed individuals providing mental health counseling there could be other types of Thank you.
of my head that piece of information um certainly you know there may be risk to schools if you had completely unlicensed individuals providing mental health counseling there could be other types of risks that are at play and some of that may come into what the definition of counseling is but i would imagine you know if they were seeing a kind of a if there's a psychiatrist or a kind of a licensed counselor in the school there would be records being kept of those conversations just as part of the course of care that would be my assumption but i don't know may follow up one one last question thank you would those records be subject to 91a by the parents because the parents i mean on 91a the right to know um the parents have an interest in what's happening with their children.
This is their school record, and they want to see.
Do you see any impediment right now to a parent saying, I want to know if my child has received this counseling in school, and I would like the records?
Would they have to go ahead and file 91A requests for those records?
I guess part of me is, and part of why I made the face when you said 91a is i don't know if i would proceed under 91a if i were a parent in that circumstance there's federal laws that would allow parent that should allow parents access to their child's educational record so not that i do this in my career but if i were advising a parent i would probably suggest they avail themselves of that and go through the 91a process but i think there are ways to get access to those records if they were a parent seeking them.
Thank you.
Senator Whitley.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Thank you for taking our questions.
My understanding would be, I think you're correct, it would be like under HIPAA or FERPA, you know, there's a lot of different ways to access records.
And I think it is this balance of privacy.
So, but my, well, there's two things that I would be interested in hearing from you.
One, the sort of line that Senator Carson raised about, of course, we want people, I fully agree.
If there's mental health treatment being provided in the schools, I fully agree it should be by people who are credentialed.
Absolutely.
But what I hear you saying is that it may not always involve mental health treatment, right?
Because just because someone has decided they are non-binary or transgender or perhaps exploring their sexuality, they don't need treatment, right?
That's just their identity.
They perhaps need someone to have a discussion Thank you.
exploring their sexuality, they don't need treatment, right?
That's just their identity.
They perhaps need someone to have a discussion with.
But I think we do need to be careful that just because someone is LGBTQ, they don't need treatment.
But my question to you is that this is a legal question, and I apologize for putting you on the spot, but this bill only lays out the rights of parents.
And some of those rights are already in other places, be it in practice or constitutional rights or statute.
I think we heard a lot of testimony that some of these rights already exist.
So do you have any concerns that because those already exist, they're being restated here, and that there's no mention of the interest or rights of children, that somehow by restating them in this, we are elevating the rights of parents over the rights of children?
Do you have any legal concerns about that?
part yes part no um i I think, you know, one, I think there's an important balancing here, obviously, between the rights of the parents and the rights of the child.
Like, you know, it's not to say parents' rights don't matter.
It's not to say children's rights don't matter.
It's finding that balance.
But I think, you know, in terms of statutory interpretation, it does create complexity.
If you have two statutes saying the same thing and there are differences between the two, that might be something that the New Hampshire Supreme Court looks to to say, well, we have to, because this law is, whether it's more specific, whether it is more recent, whether it is more detailed, we have to look to that as the touchstone for interpretation.
And so we're going to not necessarily consider these other laws, because they're going to try to harm, but they are generally going to try to harmonize the laws together as best they can.
And so if that means that, you know, other statutes that might have a little bit more, like might have some balancing that maybe skews more in favor of the child, then maybe to harmonize those that they look to protecting the child's rights more maybe than the parents.
But if there isn't, or if there's a law that's, you know, more protective of the parents' rights, depending on the circumstances, they might skew it more in that direction.
It would be hard to kind of really get into the details without having a specific kind of comparison point there.
Follow up?
Thank you.
So the sort of related question is that, you know, this idea of balancing interests, of course, you know, parents have these fundamental rights, you know, and, but also children have, children have rights too, right?
To be safe, you know, other rights.
And so, you know, I guess that I'm concerned with this sort of off-balance approach, right?
If we're only talking about parents' rights and not even mentioning children's rights, that's the balance that I'm concerned about.
And I'm wondering if you have any concerns about that.
I don't know if you read the the report from the Massachusetts Office of Child Advocate in the Harmony Montgomery case, which said that Massachusetts essentially elevated the rights of parents over the right of Harmony Montgomery.
and that was of course a very problematic situation that resulted in who knows what right and so do you have any concerns that you know this is sort of you know we have a house And that was, of course, a very problematic situation that resulted in who knows what.
Right.
And so do you have any concerns that, you know, this is sort of, you know, we have a House version, we have a Senate version that, you know, either version would upset that balance to elevate the right of a parent over the right of a child who could potentially be subject to abuse and neglect?
I think, you know, the balance is key in these circumstances.
I'm going to, you know, Because the idea is the child who is, you know, kind of a teenager questioning coming out, trying to decide whether to come out, they could have the most supportive parents in the world in that process.
But that doesn't maybe eliminate the fear because, you know, they just don't, it's different when it's you.
It's different when it is you making that choice and what might happen as a result, what in your life might change as a result.
And so the concern here with that balance is making sure to kind of protect that child from being kind of put through what could be, you know, even with support parents, a very traumatic experience of kind of uncertainty and letting them kind of come to terms and be able to prepare to do that on their own and when they are ready and able to do that.
And so that's, I think, the concern with the balance.
There's finding that right balance.
And it's a difficult balance to find.
I'm not going to pretend it's not.
But it's that important balance and kind of a process that might force a child, even in the rare circumstance through a very difficult process that leads to a bad result, is going to be, I mean, it's a bad result at the end of the day.
There's no preventing that.
Senator Gannon.
Thanks, Attorney Locke, for taking my question.
Senator Carson asked a lot of what I wanted to say, so I'll be really brief.
You talked about a 14-year hypothetical 14-year-old, and you said, you know, their thought process developed yet.
So you're saying legally they lack capacity to do a lot of things, correct?
But in any sense, anyone under the age of 18 is going to have a lot of legal capacity.
Thank you.
So the parents are responsible for the health, education, welfare of that child, right?
They're the family unit.
The primary thing is parents, correct?
Legally.
Yes.
Okay.
And so if you keep information from them, so the state or schools is for liability reasons.
Something happens to my child, they harm themselves at home.
And I was totally unaware that they were having this issue or problem that they questioned their sexuality whatever the case is you've kept that from me is not the state and the school going to have huge liability issues for not informing the parents well i think that's where i mentioned like there may be circumstances where you do have to disclose that information it's not you know you can't necessarily have this kind of code of silence you have like there may be circumstances where if the child like if the child is engaging in dangerous behavior or if they're the target of bullying and harassment by other students you may have to explain to the parents why that's happening even if the child doesn't want you to do that i mean certainly plenty of kids on this player or not player and athletic fields anything like that they'll call each other names whether it's founded or not but if you know if you know there's it's putting the student at risk yes you may have to kind of expound the student whether they want that or not to make sure they're adequately protected so just one last follow-up so continuing on senator carson's theme of certain educators certain officials uh teachers whoever really don't have a mental health background.
And so my 13-year-old, she probably, between coaches, dance teachers, counselors at the school, anything, she's seeing 15 to 20 people per year who are going to be teaching, instructing her.
They're there for a very short period of time, seven, eight months, then we're going on to the next 15 or 20 are you not afraid that you're taking away the parental main function of i know the kid i've been there i've been there with them from birth i want the best for them and if you these people who don't have a background in mental health education are making these decisions of what when to come forward when the kid comes to them don't you think they always need to come forward unless there's a danger and that's why we have dcyf a mandated reporter well i think the issue here though is it's facilitating the child to be able to come forward it's not the teacher that decides i mean this would be to flip that around a little bit i mean this is the legislature deciding when the parent gets to find out and when the child has to disclose this information.
But in this context, it's, you know, the teacher's facility, the idea would be the teacher, the guidance counselor, whoever it is working with this child is facilitating them to be able to do that when they are able to, when they feel safe, comfortable, and ready to do so.
It's not, you know, them making the choice unilaterally to say, this is when you're going to tell, like, you're telling your parents next week, or I'm telling them.
It's, you know, I'm going to give you the tools to be able to prepare yourself to do this and have this conversation.
Because if they're afraid, I might end up homeless.
And maybe let's make sure there are services, like our social worker has services in place if that happens.
So you don't end up on the street, you end up in a supportive environment.
And it may be an unfounded fear at the end of the day and i will you know fully acknowledge that thank you senator carson thank you madam chair i think attorney lock you really kind of put your finger on what i am concerned about one of the things anyway is that a child is receiving medical treatment whether it's met its mental health counseling without the permission One of the things, anyway, is that a child is receiving medical treatment, whether it's mental health counseling, without the permission of the parents.
They're in school to be educated, not to receive mental health counseling.
That's not the purpose of sending the child to school.
And so when a child receives mental health counseling, you don't know anything about the type of counseling you don't know if the counselor is adequately that do they have the education the certificate everything that they need in order to be a good counselor for your child you are kept literally in the dark you have no idea and that I find very problematic that the parents just you just feel well the school knows better than the parent and that is not the case your child is receiving medical treatment mental health counseling and the parents don't even know they have no idea and there's no obligation to inform the parents much like if like I said your child was in the school they fell down and they needed stitches they would take your child to the hospital and you'd have to go there and give your permission for that to happen but with schools it seemed that it's in this instance it's very very different and it really shouldn't be it really shouldn't be if my child is going to get mental health counseling at school i want to make sure that that person is qualified to do that type of counseling with my child but because no one is being told i don't get to make that decision for my child.
I don't get to be involved in that process with my child.
It's happening during school.
So it's basically saying the schoolhouse doors are closed, you stay over there, and we're going to stay here.
And that's not the way it was ever intended to be.
I appreciate the concern you've expressed.
Part of, I guess, the way I would maybe question some of that assessment is I'm not sure, you know, if a student say, I'm questioning my sexual orientation, they're really getting mental health counseling at the end.
I mean, is that, what is being treated there?
What is the psychiatric or medical condition being treated?
If a student says, look, I'm questioning my sexuality, I'm worried about coming out to my parents because of their reaction, it may be counseling in a very broad sense in the way that we go to each other to seek life advice about, you know, I have to make an employment decision or I have to make a difficult decision in my life, but is it mental health counseling at the end of the day in the sense of this person is getting psychiatric services that would require medical care i it's i just kind of been struggling a little bit with that comparison thank you madam chair i disagree with your analogy about going to a friend um you know your friend they don't probably have a background in mental health you just they know me they you know hey i'm struggling with this this is what's going on what do you think but you have to think about the dynamic between a child and a teacher or a counselor at school very very very different dynamic um i'm good well they're a teacher they're they're here there's a mental health counselor or a guidance counselor they're up here they're in a position of power over that student whereas if you're just talking to a friend you don't have that type of power dynamic it doesn't exist and you get to choose so my concern here is we are now treading into an area that we just aren't prepared to deal with I don't know.
So my concern here is we are now treading into an area that we just aren't prepared to deal with.
Our schools certainly are not if they're offering this type of counseling, because even you had mentioned that to help them prepare to come out.
That is a process.
that is not a one and done where I'm going to sit with somebody for, you know, a half an hour with a friend and I'm going to talk about this.
This is going to be a process.
That is actual counseling on how to do this.
So I think the schools are putting themselves at a huge liability.
I think the teachers are putting themselves at a huge liability, as well as the administrators.
And I think we really need to take a step back and we need to look at what is actually going on here.
Because as I said, the schoolhouse doors are closed, parents are over there.
And is it that is that the role for the schools?
Schools are creatures of a community.
They've created the schools.
Is that what they want to go on in their schools?
And no one's asked the questions.
Nobody has talked about it.
So this bill just basically says, these are the rights of the parents.
Parents are legally responsible to their children.
Parents can be arrested if they abandon their children, can be arrested if they neglect their children.
But why are we picking and choosing?
And it's not about elevating the rights of one over the other.
We have recognized here in the state that when it comes to these very, very difficult decisions, unlike Massachusetts in the Harmony Montgomery case, we have elevated that we have to do what's in the best right of the children in these types of very, very difficult abuse and neglect cases.
But we're not talking about abuse and neglect cases.
That's not what we're talking about here.
We're talking about parents who put their kids on a school bus to go to school.
And do they have a right to know what's going on in that school?
Because I think we all know kids aren't going to, kids are kids.
We were all there.
We never told our parents everything that was happening in school.
We just don't.
But the fundamental question is, do parents have the right?
And then beyond that, okay, if the schools are going to assume this role, we need to put parameters around that.
So that's where the Senate is.
And I think to answer the question of do they have the right, I think there are, like as I mentioned earlier, there are statutes and laws that would allow parents access to this information when they seek it the difference here is this puts the affirmative obligation on the school to inform the parents thank you thank you thank you very much i appreciate it um so to go on to the next um thing that we heard a lot from the domestic violence advocates, New Hampshire Legal Assistance and New Hampshire Domestic, New Hampshire Coalition.
Thank you.
We just know it as the coalition, Madam Chair.
I know.
Sorry.
That brought up some very good points.
One being that an abuser could go into the school, request the records, and with nothing redacted, that would have the victim's current address on it.
I know when I went through it and the courts even redacted my address so he couldn't find me.
This really startles me because we don't want to do any more harm.
And also it states that both parents can be there for events at the school.
How does this protect the person that has the restraining order?
Is she not allowed to go or he?
Are they not allowed to go?
I'm going to be honest.
I feel like a lot of issues were brought up after the fact.
It would have been nice to have these beforehand so we could fully vet them because there's just I don't see any way I can support this because we would have to amend so much stuff to try to make this safe for people that I think it's going to take more time than what we have.
Senator Carson.
Thank you Madam Chair.
Thank you for articulating what I going to, is the fact that we didn't have testimony to any of this.
And if we had, we could have done that.
We would have been able to do that.
So I'm very disappointed in these organizations that are out there that work with victims of domestic violence, why they didn't come to the table, why they didn't come to the hearing and talk about this issue, because we certainly could have dealt with it when the Senate was in possession with the bill.
Thank you.
Senator Whitley?
Yeah, well, I just, I mean, to be fair, the Senate amended the bill in executive session.
So we didn't have a hearing on the version that gave many, many people pause about the LGBTQ issues.
We just didn't have a hearing on that.
So I just want to be a little bit fair about that.
They, you know, there wasn't an opportunity to publicly provide input because it was an executive session.
So that's why they had to come to us after.
And I think there were also some changes that we made on the floor to try to fix it that have raised other issues that, you know, the coalition is now addressing.
So I just wanted to be a little bit fair about that, that, you know, the legislative process is complicated and we are making changes.
And so as those changes are happening, you know, these groups have to respond.
And I think they've responded appropriately.
And I know that when the House sent it over to the Senate, we sent what was already in statute because but we wanted them to have one place where they could find what was already in statute.
Right.
As far as the rights that are already there.
But I just don't I I honestly think that this is just going to need a lot more work.
And I mean, I think that's going to be something that can be worked on over the summer.
But I just, I cannot agree to this in its present form.
And to no fault of anyone, we did get all this information afterwards because of the way the process goes but i i just i can't so um i don't know if you guys want to see to the house position for what is already in statute but um yeah this is the conversation yeah so do we want to take um Senator, you have a 3 o'clock.
Yeah, I have a 3 o'clock.
How long do you think you guys will need to take a little break?
Yeah, you can recess until.
I can't.
Oh, yeah.
Recess.
We can take a break.
No, no, you need to recess because if you, if we say, okay, and we'll meet at a different, you need 24-hour notice.
Right.
So if we recess for, you know, beginning at 3 o'clock for 45 minutes until, you know, whenever for 45 minutes, I'll go, we'll come back, and then we can get back together.
Okay, because I was told not to use the word recess unless I'm recessing to a different date and time.
So I'm going to say we're going to take a break until 3 45.
Is that?
Yeah, that should be okay.
Yes.
So if we do nothing, are we then saying to parents that schools can keep secrets from you?
No, I think we're saying to parents that we want to make sure we do it right because that's what's in the best interest of their children and to the victims of domestic violence, what's in the best interest of their safety.
Can I, I just, I mean, I want parents to understand they have rights.
That's why when we sent it over from the house, those were already in statute.
We took out the penalties.
We brought it over just what was in statute.
so it could be in one place for parents to easily find because I think they're having a problem with um knowing where to look I mean if you're not up here doing this job it's very hard to know where to go to look for things you know so that's you know what we did but and and whatever, I lost my train of thought, I'm so sorry, but Senator Whitley.
So, I mean, I think on the House version, there were we had heard from the department, the DCYF, Joe Ripsom had sent the Judiciary Committee, the Senate Judiciary Committee, a letter about the House version saying that there were some problems on the abuse and neglect side.
So I just wanted you to know that we had heard that it would interfere with their authority to do abuse and neglect.
And then also the House version had criminal penalties.
I thought we took those criminal penalties out because that was not the intent.
I did not intend to send anything with criminal penalties.
So we'll come back at 345.
We'll take a break and then come back and see where we are.
Thank you.
We'll have to put in a bill requiring schools if they're going to do this type of council Thank you.
Okay.
So.
I could offer the House version as amended, but amend it to remove the penalties.
So where's the Senate on that?
So I appreciate that the penalties are problematic, but when the House version came over to the Senate Judiciary Committee, we got a letter from Joe Ribson, the director of DCYF, saying that.
And I apologize.
I should have poured it during the break.
But he essentially told us that the way that the House version is written, he's very concerned that it would interfere with DCYF's ability to conduct abuse and neglect investigations.
And also we heard from the Office of Child Advocate, Maura, at the time that the way it was written could lead to the unintended consequences of sort of permitting abuse and neglect on children.
Okay.
So you guys had time for a break.
I didn't.
Oh, I'm sorry.
You didn't.
I was in another committee conference.
I'm sorry.
So then I can't in good faith support this the way it is.
I just can't.
I would be, now that we have the information we need, I would be happy to prime sponsor this bill next year by, but fixing it with the information that we have, because I don't think we can fix it in two days.
But if we have the summer to really, um, get it done, work with the sponsors of the bill and have the concerns, then I would be more than happy to do that.
But I just can't do it this way because it just needs too much work to really try to fix in two days.
Well, Madam Chair, the only thing that I'm going to say is it's a shame.
It really and truly is a shame that all these groups that contacted us between the time that it was passed in the Senate up until now did not come to the table when the bill was in the Senate.
We could have addressed their issues.
We could have fixed everything.
And it's a shame.
It's shameful.
And it is not the way that people should be operating.
I don't know why they weren't paying attention, why they didn't see what we were doing, because everything we do is totally transparent in front of everyone.
Yes, there was an amendment.
The amendment was brought in during an executive session.
Anybody who knows me, we make those available to anybody who's there.
They can read them.
If they have questions, I allow people to ask questions, talk about their concerns about any amendment that comes forward.
People did not avail themselves of that and to submarine a good piece of legislation at this point because people did not take the initiative to be there at the table i think people really need to rethink how they're going to relate to the legislature on any particular issue going forward if you have a concern be there at the table we'd be more than happy to work with you.
But to do what has been done on this bill, I find extremely problematic.
And I understand that, but I think that the point is now that we have this information, and I just don't think in good faith that we can go forward.
I think that we take all of this into consideration, and then we come back with the proper bill in the fall.
And that's where we are.
Well, thank you very much, and thank you very much for your time.
Thank you.
it has four parts to it as we've seen number one no one should be required to receive a covid19 vaccination in order to receive benefits or services from dhhs we saw that reestablishes a special supplemental nutrition program for women infant and children's farmers market nutrition three requires the insurance commissioner to establish a pilot program for association health plans four directs the department of hhs to submit a state plan amendment to expand the postpartum coverage under medicaid the chair would like to recognize Senator Bradley to speak to item number four because he is I WANT TO READ THE RECOGNIZE OF THE MEDICAID.
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR BRADLEY TO SPEAK TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR BECAUSE HE HAS BROUGHT FORTH AN AMENDMENT.
IF I HAVE IT IN THE RIGHT SPOT.
DO I?
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
BASED ON THE CONVERSATION based on the conversation that we had yesterday and based on a further conversation I had after the committee conference with Representative Hunt, I am proposing this amendment.
I have not had the opportunity to talk to Representative Hunt about it because he's obviously not able to be here today, but I think it addresses many of his concerns.
And his concern was that no one's ever going to bid on a pilot program.
Why should we even go forward with it?
So what I am proposing is that the Department of Insurance publish a request for information.
That's a normal process that a department would go through to gauge the interest in establishing a pilot program for an associated health plan.
and then it's the rest of the language because if there is going to be a pilot program we need to protect state mandated coverages and all the other things that were in it.
A thousand participants comply with the AHP final rule, all that kind of stuff.
So it would have to be based on those criteria.
if there's no interest there's no we haven't the department hasn't had to jump through hoops to try be based on those criteria if there's no interest there's no um we haven't the department hasn't had to jump through hoops to try to put together a pilot program they put out a request for information gauge the interest we see what happens you've been all given a copy of that amendment.
Does anyone have any questions for the senator?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
Senator Bradley, I'm a little slow on the uptake here, so I just want to roll back through my understanding of what we're trying to do here.
And if you would, just, uh, my ego won't be bruised.
I, I, I, when I think of an association health plan, I'm thinking of, uh, professionals that bond together, whether they be attorneys, whether they be engineers or whatever, they, they can form their own health insurance plan.
They can manage the collection of their own premiums, and they can manage the negotiation with the hospitals or whoever.
And so this is, if that's correct, then what you're proposing is a new player in the marketplace on the payer side.
Is that what we're doing?
We're increasing competition on the payer side?
That would be the hope of an associated health plan.
As Representative Hunt pointed out yesterday, we already have the MIWA statute, but nobody uses it because it's kind of prescriptive.
So the thought that Senator Rashardi, because it's her bill, had was to try a pilot program to see if on a small basis, a thousand lives, there would be interest in a pilot program to learn from it and see what, you know, see what might occur.
So it's as much information gathering as anything.
I think Chairman Hunt expressed his reservations, as we all heard, yesterday.
So having heard those, and a lot of it was, why should the department go through with doing something that, in his opinion, Representative Hunt's, nobody's likely to bid on.
Okay, I get that.
This means that the department would just put out an RFI and see what interest there is.
If there's no interest, then end of discussion.
if there is interest then we may want to come back next year with something that would formalize it again.
But this is just the very first step in the...
Follow up?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So as I'm looking at your amendment, I don't see any dollars.
So is this going to be cost-free to the state except for the intrinsic overhead associated with putting together an RFI and collecting the responses?
And you're assuming that is already in the budget and there's not additional money for that.
As I recall in the testimony, representative, they never asked for an appropriation to put together the full pilot program.
This would be even less than, so you're right.
There's no appropriation, should be no impact on state finances.
Thank you.
Any additional questions of the Senator?
I'm going to ask a question that I've asked in a few other committees of conference.
Given that this bill has four parts, the original House bill and then three additional add-ons, is it likely to be the Senate's will that it's all or nothing, or do you wish to vote on each item as a standalone, that in fact what passes could be one, two, or three of these items?
Certainly we have not caucused on that particular issue, and so I would not be ready to give you an answer quite yet would you like to take 10 minutes to do so and before they do you know what mr.
chair if I could make a suggestion why don't we go through each item and as I thought yesterday we actually were fairly close to a consensus if we're not then maybe we'll take a quick caucus i appreciate that let's try that representative edwards well this this plays off of what senator bradley just said i just wanted to revisit the dollar amount that we were talking about on wick um i i had said that I was willing to go as high as 30,000 and there was other ranges, 50 to a hundred thousand.
Um, and, and Lisa, I, I, I'm so horrible with last names.
Um, but I, I, and I'm hard at hearing too.
So this is just horrible.
I live in a hell.
Can we ask Lisa to come up and maybe talk to us about how much money they really need for the implementation of this program?
We can't, but I, as the chair can.
Ooh, that was awful.
Please come on up chairman pearson members of the community conference uh i have with me today for the record for myself i'm john williams director of legislative affairs for health and services and with me is lisa soroes director for the wick program for the uh the division of Health Services.
Representative Edwards, you may inquire or ask.
Okay.
So my theory on this bill, rather than $300,000, what we really needed to do was to invest $30,000 because $30,000 would be the right amount to get the program started.
It would do three things at least.
It would let you show the feds the $10,000 good faith money on the personnel.
It would let you have money to do an RFI to start getting the farmers markets moving.
and it would allow you to print coupons that would be effective July 1 of 2023 that there would not be any money for July 1 2023 to September 30th because that's in the next budget year however if we got this bill passed this would be allowing the department to include it in the normal business, normal order of the governor's budget process.
and as a result, next spring, we'd just be looking at what the amount is that you think you would need for July 1 to September 30 of 23 and then the same period in 24 since it'd be a two-year budget okay what did I say there the the you disagree with no I agree that that that could work follow up I was just gonna ask if there anybody wanted to ask you questions about the $30,000.
Do you want me to clarify why there's that stark difference between $30,000 and $300,000?
Please.
So the $300,000 includes the food dollars for the coupons, but it is not possible to get this program up and running for july 1st this year so that 270 000 isn't necessary today but for us to have the 30 000 admin dollars that will give us time to get the program up and running so july 1st of next summer we will need that 270 000 for food dollars to make it happen which which is what Representative Edwards has outlined.
I'm good with that.
I just wanted to make sure she was available to answer any questions.
So it sounds like $30,000 will do it to get the program going.
Yes.
The rest will be in the budget, we hope.
Okay, good.
Yes.
Senator Gray.
Well, certainly $30,000 is what a minimum that I would accept.
But, you know, certainly I want to push the department, you know, to do what they can to provide fresh fruit, vegetables, and herbs.
I got them all right, I think, this time.
You know, to the individuals.
And I'm not necessarily thinking that, you know, part of the department has felt the pressure that we want to put on them to get this program up and running.
And if the scope of it were to expand some, then I don't know that $30,000 is sufficient.
Can you get this program into the theoretical phase so that when we have enough time to get something going, will $30,000 do it?
Yes.
Thank you.
Senator Bradley.
I, for one, can accept $30,000 if this gets us to yes on the overall package, because I suspect what will happen, Senator Whitley will ask Representative Edwards to sponsor a bill that she co-sponsors next year that Center that Representative Edwards will fold into House Bill 2 and we'll see it in the Senate if I may so we we're going to pass we're going to pass this bill that creates the program and so we don't even need another bill we'll just work together to make sure it is in the budget.
So hearing, and what I'm hearing is a commitment to put it in the budget.
Thank you.
Sounds like we have a plan.
Let's see, what we're doing.
So, straw vote, item number two.
Thank you.
I guess I'll go first.
I'm okay with your second item.
You okay with two?
I'm good with two.
Item two?
Okay, so that one's done.
And yes, that is at 30.
Item one clarifies no person shall be required to receive a COVID-19 vaccination in order to receive benefits or services from DHHS.
I seem to remember we were all good on that.
Is that true?
Yes.
I hear at least eight votes good somebody's a little humor twice okay let's do four because we just talked about it um senator bradley's amendment um that is i see it as well i think it's four isn't it is it three oh okay sorry three and we like uh three as amended he does i'm sure he does senator gray you like yeah yeah i wouldn't say no okay i'm going to take that as a yes it's a not no and representative king and me yes we are three quarters of the way home.
Now let's talk about four.
Anybody wish to speak to four?
Please do.
Okay, so as I understand this line item, this refers to the bill that went through the House, through HHS, through Division III, and got passed by the entire House to go ahead and allow Medicaid reimbursement for postpartum services between two months and 12 months for those making somewhere between 130% of family poverty or federal poverty and 296%.
And that that would potentially affect 570 families, of which about 25% may actually take advantage of the benefit.
And I don't think there are any, this is the big one, I don't think there are any amendments that have been floated by anyone on this committee of conference to change that underlying bill.
Is that a correct assumption or a bad assumption?
So I don't even really know how this got in here because the House passed it.
Did the Senate not want to just vote on it?
We put this, we did, we put it in here because when the House passed it, they attached something that the Senate had already rejected.
Wow.
What was the number?
1210.
So, Representative Edwards, this became the bill that Representative Edwards what was the number well so representative edwards this became the bill that representative um lang's bill 1210 which was the right of conscience for vaccines got attached to we had voted that bill down two or three weeks ago, 12-10.
The House amendment attached it on the floor.
It was a Turcotte-Osborne amendment.
It passed 162 to 153 to attach it to 407.
We non-concurred.
And subsequent, and we put 407 into 1099.
Going back to the division work session, you had several in the House.
You had one on April 25th.
You had another one on April 26th.
You had an executive session on April 27th.
The committee report was 20 to 0, and it went to the floor.
Then you had the roll call on the floor amendment, and then the overall bill with the other floor amendment passed 295 to 28.
So I think suffice it to say, House Finance unanimously supported the 200K.
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So just to be clear and i'm i'm asking you about your memory more than mine and that is um there was also a cushman bill that created some immunization exemption exemptions for religious grounds.
Yeah.
Yes the case.
you The House concurred with the senate amendment and the concurrence motion was representative pearson's motion so that bill passed okay thank you so much for that now we could talk about 1210 if you want to know why we didn't support it.
No, I don't.
Okay, I don't either.
And that's because the Cushman bill, when it came to Division III, we beefed up the religious exemption side of it.
We left the middle one alone, I think.
I don't remember what the middle exemption was.
I should.
And we got rid of the conscience exemption because there was no analogy in the Medicare-Medicaid provisions for conscience, and we didn't want to jeopardize our Medicaid funding.
So we stripped that out.
So that's a long way around saying that as long as this postpartum component isn't affecting the Cushman religious exemption part of it and it's only you only stripped out the conscience part then I'm good with it representative Lang's bill is a little different than representative Cushman's bill as I recall and I'd have and I can look back if you want me to at the text.
I think that Representative Cushman's bill just dealt with New Hampshire Hospital and Glencliffe, both of which are Medicaid eligible.
So there was an impact there.
Hats off to you, Jess, sorry, Representative Edwards.
You did a great job in Division III.
The same pressure that we were under on Representative Lang's bill, 1210, which had an impact because it was broader than just Representative Cushman's bill on hospitals, doctors, anybody that not only took Medicaid patients, but Medicare.
And we just, even though I think some of us felt that, you know, people shouldn't be getting fired.
It was like, what do you do?
And, you know, if Medicaid and Medicare funding were going to be threatened.
And I think just as you found, when you looked at 1604, there was a credible threat that you did the right thing, and I think we did the right thing on 1210.
But when 1210 came back to us on Senate Bill 407, the postpartum bill, then that's when we attached it to this.
I truly appreciate summary and um and so mr chair i think the the the takeaway is that this postpartum component is the house position yes yes yes yes yes yes yes well i see four items and they're all good so taken as a whole yes or no position is that we support the bill as amended by the bradley amendment and the thirty thousand dollars how do we make the 30 000 change i don't i don't oh well that's good Yeah, they'll do something.
We can get down together.
Yeah.
And we'll sign off on that.
I think it's just a change in the appropriation.
They'll need to do a consolidated amendment for both the Bradley change and the 30,000.
And you need to write your report because the House procedure has, you know, different than the Senate procedure.
And it'll probably be ready to sign off, I would guess, by noontime tomorrow.
Sounds like a plan.
We're done.
Thank you, everybody.
Senator Gray, reminder, you have a meeting in Rochester.
Thank you for reminding me.
Thank you.
In action, I should make it.
Okay.